previously on film theory Dori remember
the boats but then forget meeting Marlin
I am on to you Ellen DeGeneres keep
swimming swimming finding Dory more like
exposing Dory the truth is coming out
Dory doesn't suffer from short-term
memory loss she's faking it
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film wait what
was I saying
see if I hadn't arrow great amnesia like
Dory claims I wouldn't remember what I'm
supposed to say here but as we talked
about last time Dory doesn't have
anterograde amnesia she's faking her
condition to look weaker and have the
other fish underestimate her abilities
it's a survival tactic oh sure
everything seems to check out she can't
remember Marlins name she forgets where
she is can't even remember what happened
to her parents sit as we found last
episode she slips up she remembers
seeing the boat that took Nemo even
after she claims to forget who Marlin is
this fact of seeing the boat should fall
under declarative memory which if she
was truly suffering from short-term
memory loss
she should have forgotten you've painted
yourself into a corner dory and that's
not the only piece of evidence I have
against you today we're throwing the
book at dory to show that appearances
can be deceiving and to get you to view
finding Dory in a whole new context and
here's the crazy thing to start exposing
Dory's lies we don't even need to look
that deep it all begins with the single
most basic fact about Dory the type of
fish she is now finding Nemo never
specifies her species but judging by her
blue body and the black design running
out to her yellow tail we can
confidently say that Dory is a blue tang
also known as a parrot can therus
hepatis Latin for incredibly hard to
pronounce these fish tend to be
relatively small growing up to only 12
inches when they reach adulthood and
look at that peaceful majesty
and yes it's time to explore some true
facts about the blue tang that curvy
blue body hides a caudal spine which
extends out when threatened slashing and
wounding predators that make story like
the Wolverine of fish snikt indeed and
that's not all if consumed by humans
blue tangs may cause poisoning and some
blue tang fish even have venomous glands
in their fins Wow
Dory is far less cute than Finding Nemo
would have you believe behind that
angelic blue body and freckled big eyed
face lurks a venomous monster say Frank
I miss you and your true facts series
come back to YouTube come back but okay
let's go back to the whole memory loss
thing Dory states that the source of our
short-term memory loss is hereditary I
forget things almost instantly it runs
in my family this may be a simple
reference to the old myth of goldfish
memory the belief that fish are dumb and
have short memory spans only able to
recall events for about three seconds or
so this though is just not true not a
true fact about the blue tang fish
actually have surprisingly strong
memories lasting for up to a year carp
that have been caught by fishermen have
been seen to avoid hooks for up to a
year afterwards researchers even
discovered that they could learn to
associate certain sounds with food and
then remember it five months later there
is ample evidence that fish are just as
intelligent as mammals capable of the
same intellectual feats as a rats or
mice they can learn their way around
mazes they can learn to recognize other
fish and they can remember prey from
predator
thus we can't dismiss Dory short-term
memory loss as just being symptomatic of
her being a fish so the question remains
then can you inherit short-term memory
loss from your parents the answer here
once again is a big no short-term memory
loss is typically caused in one of two
ways
drug and alcohol abuse or severe brain
trauma benzodiazepine drugs typically
used to treat panic attacks if misused
can cause amnesia induced side effects
drinking a bunch of alcohol can cause
blackouts which blocks the brain's
ability to transfer short-term memories
into long-term memory so if you go out
on a late-night bender and can't
remember what happened to you the night
before congratulations you
gave yourself anterograde amnesia a
winner is you and chronic alcoholism can
lead to Korsakoff syndrome where brain
cells are unable to produce enough
energy and as a result breakdown and
cause permanent anterograde amnesia so
unless Dory is regularly swimming her
way out of a bourbon bottle not gonna do
it although that would be a very
different movie new from Pixar an
uplifting family-friendly story of one
fish's struggle to combat alcoholism
coming this summer finding dory in the
gutter on the other side traumatic brain
injury typically to the hippocampus and
surrounding cortices can also cause
anterograde amnesia or to treat a
serious disorder like epilepsy or a
tumor patients will have parts of their
brain removed these procedures
successfully cure the disorder but can
often result in anterograde amnesia
notice though that none of these
instances brain trauma alcohol and drug
abuse are hereditary in fact there is no
scientific proof that anterograde
amnesia has ever been passed down
genetically none Dory unless she's a
unicorn of biology quite simply is lying
about the cause of her amnesia which
again throws into question her having
amnesia in the first place
but that sounds crazy right people
faking an illness as extreme as amnesia
but here's the thing it's not as crazy
as it sounds in fact it's so common it
even has a name faking amnesia would be
considered a type of malingering in
which people fake symptoms of an illness
to achieve some goal getting out of work
getting taken care of or in Dory's case
increasing your odds of survival in the
dangerous ocean so outside of the
scientific and consistencies in our
story how do we prove how it right prove
that she's malingering well it's not as
hard as you might think most fakers tend
to ferrisbueller their symptoms over
exaggerate them by putting an extra
effort to make them look sick the key to
faking out the parents is the clammy
hands take for instance the hand coin
test if I put a quarter in my right hand
you can easily tell me which hand the
coin is in unless of course you weren't
paying attention xx Pixar lover 15
there's always one of you geez you think
I do these videos for my health or
something I'm doing this for you anyway
to catch you up the coin is in my right
hand
amnesiacs though can't remember which
hand the coin is in and are forced to
guess meaning that by the laws of
probability they'll guess correctly
around 50% of the time
fakers though will exaggerate their bad
performance they'll remember which hand
the coin is in and to look sick will
deliberately choose the wrong one as a
result their tally of correct to
incorrect guesses will be below chance
they're throwing the test but they're
throwing it a bit too hard and when it
comes to short-term memory-loss there's
a bunch of proven scientific tests to
catch you in the act these tests are
referred to as symptom validity tests
for example the tests of memory
malingering otherwise known as tom is a
50 question visual recognition test
where examinees are shown 50 drawings
numbers words or symbols for around 3
seconds each after all the drawings have
been shown the examiner then shows the
examinees two different drawings one
from the 50 previously shown and one new
one the examinee is then asked to name
which of the two drawings he had
previously seen by purely guessing an
amnesiac would score 50 percent right
and across all of these tests it was
found that suspected malingerers scored
worse than actual and tarot grade
amnesiacs and that's not at all
malingerers tend to have a slower
response time to questions they take
great pains and answering as if they're
struggling to figure out what the
correct answer was hmm that's a tough
one Oh true amnesiacs however tend not
to have that much delay between question
and answer and finally psychologists use
what's known as the primacy effect to
test so-called amnesiacs
this is the tendency to more easily
remember items from the beginning of a
list rather than the middle so if I give
you the numbers 8 to 9 6 3 5 5 9 6 -
you're most likely to remember the
number 8 because it was the first number
of the bunch
fakers show this effect people with
amnesia don't knowing all that look at
dorri dorri like most malingerers
consistently answer questions wrong far
below mere chance
midway through Finding Nemo a school of
fish try to give Dory directions by
showing her a number of different sea
creatures however Dory is unable to
identify a single one failing to
recognize a swordfish a lobster and an
octopus now you're probably thinking hey
mat Pat give Dory a break maybe she
can't remember what an octopus or
swordfish are called she does have an
Terry
neasha after all except dory previously
has shown that she has quite a knack for
remembering different aquatic life she
easily identifies a shark a whale even a
seagull so how come right then and there
she's unable to come up with three very
common sea creatures sure maybe she
can't name one or two but all three it's
almost like she's deliberately getting
them wrong playing into her short-term
memory-loss answering way below chance
and in that scene Dory agonizes over her
answers much like a malingerer would she
exaggerates her condition a telltale
sign of a faker you want more proof look
no further than all the times Dory gets
Nemo's name wrong if she calls him Fabio
Chico bingo Harpo Elmo now the fact that
Dory can't remember Nemo's name is
consistent with anterograde amnesia but
look closely at all the names she calls
him they all end with an O just like
Nemo but someone really suffering from
anterograde amnesia would be just as
likely to call Nemo John or Paul or
Ringo they would have no idea no context
that his name would end with an O the
very fact that Dory chooses names that
are close to Nemo but not quite is proof
that she remembers his name and is
deliberately struggling and trying to
get them wrong Dory even recalls
information in accordance with the
primacy effect she memorizes the address
for where Nemo is being held P Sherman
42 Wallaby Way Sydney get in her moving
speech to Marlin at the end of the movie
she struggles to remember the complete
address only able to identify the
beginning just like a faker would be
Sherman 42 42 in fact throughout Finding
Nemo Dory shows inconsistent based
knowledge when she meets Bruce the shark
she's not scared at all like she doesn't
know what sharks are that they eat fish
yet later after discovering a scuba mask
she correctly identifies sharks below
her
and then one more time by the end of the
film she tells the Sharks to remember
not to eat fish so which way is a dory
do you remember what a shark is or not
do you remember that they eat fish or
knots cuz if you didn't know that they
eat fish the first time you met them
then you shouldn't remember hours and
days later at the end of the movie when
you see them again so which is it Dory
do you know whether sharks eat fish or
not checkmate checkmate you fictional
computer animated fish you we gotcha so
you always thought Finding Nemo as a
wholesome tale about a good-hearted
Father finding his kidnapped son with
the help of a lovable but simple-minded
companion nope let me break down what's
really happening here Dory completely
alone sees another lone fish screaming
about his missing child a kindred spirit
and easy mark Dory uses her perceived
weakness to trick predators like the
shark whale jellyfish angler fish who
all just by what Dory's selling when
Marlin attempts to get away from her
Dory immediately begins to cry
emotionally manipulating the clownfish
to take her along with him over the
course of the film she pretends to
slowly get better linking her perceived
progress with Marlin
now Marlin can't leave Dory out of guilt
because he thinks he's the only thing
keeping her together and that is the
true story of Finding Nemo how a con
artist manipulated the emotions of a
grieving father into letting her into
his home but hey that's just a theory of
film theory and cuts if you liked this
video and want the truth
tweet this at dory herself Ellen
DeGeneres
at The Ellen Show hashtag exposing Dory
you know we tried the same thing with
Leonardo DiCaprio and sent him literally
thousands of tweets and he never
responded thanks a lot for the
appreciation in us helping you get an
Oscar leo
who knows though maybe this time a big
celebrity will take notice and give this
video the response it deserves or if you
don't like pestering a celebrity voice
actor to get information about a
fictional character conspiracy theory
then click here it'll take you to the
wisecrack channel what you talk about a
bunch during these end cards but it's
because it's one of my favorite channels
on YouTube right
now seriously Jared over there the main
writer does some incredible videos that
are both hilarious and super interesting
they just did a phenomenal video on
Deadpool that blew my mind like five
times I kid you not definitely worth a
watch please if you're interested in
checking them out click here and tell
them that Matt Pat sent you and with
that I'm done for the day
next time I'm tackling something a bit
more sweet see you then
[Music]